Dina Menzel joins us in the studio it's
so good to see you hi it's great to see
you and that's very wise what you said
there it is that's what I was thinking
too Tony that the dock is so well done
with with you and
you Walker number one is such a Boy the
boy the bond that you have is so so
close yeah there's Great Moments where
you're on stage singing he's bouncing
about basketball while you're you're
you're rehearsing yeah you get off the
stage you've had this great show and the
first thing he says is can I have an
avocado
made it clear that you had to be home
for Halloween yes and you you show
yourself FaceTiming him right before you
go on stage to help with his homework so
being a mother clearly is your top
priority yet like most mothers you
struggle with the guilds I do how do you
navigate that too
um well I just keep telling myself that
I want my son to grow up seeing a
powerful women woman that chooses her
passion as well you know I think
hopefully he'll attract women like that
to his life in whatever capacity and I
just yeah I want to be there I want to
trick or treat and do all that but I
like being on stage as well you know I
like the accolades and the attention yes
and you deserve the attention I love
that you take us through your journey we
see you as a little kid your parents are
arguing I knew she was talented and she
came up out of the womb I knew when she
was three they're competing
but being at Madison Square Garden Was A
Journey For You And A Dream for you and
what it took for you to get there yes I
wanted to document a dream coming true
you know it's sort of like back in the
rent days no day but today we we learned
through that experience that we didn't
want to take things for granted and we
wanted to stay present you know in our
lives and I felt like you know this was
something I aspired to do my whole life
I want Long Island girls from here went
to NYU City girl and I always wanted to
play Madison Square Garden was actually
happening so you can't let that stuff
just pass you by you know but then I I
in in the process of filming and I
realized this is less a tour documentary
more about a mother running around like
a chicken with her head cut off trying
to navigate Both Worlds yeah when you're
talking about the dream coming true
Madison Square Garden it's a good
opportunity to talk about how careers
don't just go like this it's not one
moment of making right and I think when
you mention rent you're in rent it's a
big breakout performance it's
Off-Broadway goes to Broadway you get a
record deal but then it doesn't sell and
it gets corrupt and my album like three
albums or whatever talk about rebuilding
from there yeah
um you know I just tried it back then I
was so ambitious and I was pounding the
pavement I really believed in myself and
you just got to keep working I I'd be
songwriting I'd get on stage at some of
the smaller venues and you just I feel
like if you put yourself out there
creatively and you keep doing what you
love things come back around there's
also a really poignant moment in the
documentary because you're going through
IVF treatments at the time and that's
something a lot of women struggle with
and they sometimes feel very alone
they're doing this by themselves yes why
was it important for you to share this
I feel like our job as artists is as
long as we're protecting the people
around us is to make sure we're
vulnerable and authentic I feel like
it's the only way I really can connect
with an audience I wanted other women to
feel seen and heard in this process it's
it's uh physically and emotionally
taxing I wanted my husband to know
um how
how important he was to me you know I
already have this beautiful child but I
got remarried and he didn't have kids
and I don't know I just felt like it was
really important to to give it to give
it weight Aaron your husband is also
knock out in this piece too the bond
that you have between the two of you is
also a beautiful thing to see Adina just
last night Frozen was on I walk in these
and let it go is playing I mean where do
you stand with that do you just cringe
every time you hear it or do you just
full throat it embrace it I I embrace it
but I know people always think we get
sick of our songs but maybe being a
creature of the theater and doing eight
shows a week I'm used to trying to
discover something new and the Nuance so
that it feels fresh for me every night
and Let It Go has just been such a gift
to me it's either it's a way that I'm
connecting with a young audience you
know and really talking about
empowerment and embracing that thing in
US it makes us unique I'm glad to hear
that it's also a reminder to me as a
grown woman to keep doing that you know
honestly you know you say it's been a
gift to you but your voice your gift
it's a gift that that song is your body
you perform it so well you make it what
it is and Vlad it's going to be living
in your head oh I know I'm glad you're
ready
becoming a first time Dad in January
he's having a little girl thank you very
much
it's not just her I love Frozen too it's
a great he's a great song yeah but I
also have a lot of rent and I also love
doing Wicked it's like you have a couple
of songs I try to do a job once every
decade you know
success yeah you also addressed I was
wondering if you're going to put in the
John Travolta part because that became
oh my God but I love I love it you
included it because in that moment it
must it might have been mortifying but
you've actually turned it around and
said this was a great thing that
happened yeah
we should tell people he mispronounces
your name yeah the Grammys I think
you're about the Oscar the Oscars you're
about to perform but I love that you
included that Adina yeah well I had
about 10 seconds before after he did
that to get my
stuff together
um and and what happens in the most 10
seconds is so many things it's like I
feel sorry for myself that I'm at the
Oscars and I'm in front of Meryl Streep
and Brad Pitt and he says my name wrong
I I tell myself get out of this stop
pitying yourself sing to your child
all in about eight seconds and then I
start the first line you know but it was
a gift to me I mean everybody in the New
York world that knew me was like oh he
screwed up her name and everyone that
never heard of me said who is this yeah
who is it get it right yeah yeah right
and of course he didn't he's apologized
yes he didn't yeah so nice
everybody knows your name we're so glad
the documentary is great knockout Bravo
congratulations it's called which way to
the stage which by the way is from right
it premieres next Friday December 9th on
Disney Plus